For pal horseman wrote in from East Dawn,
they were Scouts from the red army Vanguard chasing the invaders all the way
back to Germany. It was the 27th of January, 1945 behind the Bob's,
why they found 9,000 prisoners left to die by the SS.
That place was called Auschwitz among the survivors, a young Italian,
he had been arrested because he was a resistance fighter and a Jew.
He survived because he was a chemist.
He was named Primo levy and he would become one of the most important writers of
the 20th century.
Sorry.
He was born in here in Northern Italy on the 31st of July,
1919 to Jewish parents, esta and Cesari premier inherited from treasury,
a love for reading, for science, for exploring the why's of life.
But as the ends of puberty,
the studious and introverted premier found himself in conflict with his more
outgoing father. She has a Ray encouraged his son to drink smoke,
go out with girls,
but pretty much he preferred to perform his first chemical experiments in a
friend's makeshift laboratory chemistry had become his own way of expressing an
early teenage rebellion.
His belief was that science could lead to a deeper understanding of life and the
universe. Moreover,
Primo fell to political dissonance inside his growing fascination with
chemistry, rational approach,
contrasted against the irrational soul of the growing fascist momentum all
around him.
One of fascism slogans at the time was believe a Bay fight,
but Primo was not too keen on unbelieving without understanding first as for the
other two.
Well like all his schoolmates Primo had to obey and fight in the training drills
of the fascist parties, youth organizations at this stage,
the mid 1930s Mussolini had not yet adopted racial laws at the time.
Many Jews were actually fascist supporters in September of 1937.
Primo signed up for chemistry at the university of QRN.
Then he thrived enjoying many hours,
spent in the laboratory using his hands to assemble lab equipments,
to distill elements and create compounds. So I'm away from university.
Also gave him some respite from tension at home Primo's mother,
her and found out that her husband was having an affair,
had a family history of depression and suffered from the illness itself.
So is betrayal only aggravated her status.
She projected a hatred of CSRA onto his son becoming cold distance and hostile
levies biographer.
Caroline Angia believes that it was then that Primo began to feel the effects of
clinical depression himself,
either from hereditary predispositions or triggered by environmental factors,
factors that were definitely stressful,
both inside and outside home on September the fifth, 1938,
the fascist government issued the first racial laws meant to discriminate
against Jews. Primo described his reaction as the trauma of being told,
watch out, you are not like the others. You are worse. You are a miser.
You are dirty, you are dangerous foreign on trustworthy.
Primo was never openly ostracized at university, but he didn't do a,
some isolation.
One of the few students who did not avoid him was one Sandro dumb Mastro Sandro
athletic, but not academically inclined was tutored by Primo. In exchange.
His friend introduced him to mountaineering. Primo was small and scrawny,
but with Sandra his coaching, he was able to withstand a grueling routine.
After just a few months,
the two would cycle from tierings to the nearby Alps climb,
steep mountain signs, almost bare handed,
and then cycle back at night during weekends,
they camped in the freezing cold on snow covered. Mountain tops.
Soon world war two had begun.
Darkness was encroaching Primo called it the night of Europe.
As the lights went out in the minds of many Europeans Primo realized that Sandra.
Train again for a future.
In 1941, Primo graduated with distinction,
but had no time to celebrate his father was very ill with cancer and could not
provide for the family anymore.
The young graduate needed to find a job fast and he did a young officer,
offered him a top secret job at an asbestos quarry run by the military.
That was strange enough. I mean the army employing a Jew,
the left tendons informs him that his job was not strictly official.
His duty was to synthesize nickel from the quarries waste material,
a job which may have been an army experiment or simply a Sony to gig set up by
the officer. Nonetheless, pretty much accepted the job,
adopting a false identity and never revealing his religious affiliation.
Primo proved his worth by working out an innovative process to extract nickel,
try soon damned.
And when he realized that the Nichole could benefit the axis militaries and only
case Primo superiors found his process too expensive and shut down the lab.
Premier left the quarry and accepted another job in Milan this time with a Swiss
pharmaceutical firm. Once again,
the job was top secret and he was instructed not to reveal his identity or his
religion.
His boss director martini needed a chemist to isolate phosphorus from flowers in
order to produce an oral treatment for diabetes while martini was busy,
fooling around with the secretary, Primo did his best on the job,
enjoying the company of Julia university, friends,
Primo and Julia spent more and more time together. Alas,
much like the Nobel gasses.
Julia had no intention of establishing a bond chemical or otherwise with Primo
firmly friends owned by his coworker pretty started hanging out with a group of
young Jewish men and women in Milan in November of 1942,
the allies landed in North Africa. This gave Primo and his friends.
Some hope that the fascist regime would soon be toppled.
And they joined the budding resistance movements in Northern Italy on July the
ninth, 1943. The allies landed in Sicily on the 25th muscly.
And he was deposed by his own grand council of fascism and later arrested by
King Victor manual. The third Primos underground activity,
intensified working as a liaison agent against several factions within the
resistance on the 8th of September new prime minister Marshall,
but Oleo announced this. An armistice had been signed with the allies.
The Germans were taken by surprise,
but quickly occupied Northern and central Italy establishing a new puppet.
The situation was now highly dangerous for Jews Primo left Milan for the Albus
where he joined a partisan unit consisting of 11 fighters, amateurish,
untrained, and badly equipped.
They were marked by distrust among disparate factions.
It seems the premium's unit was involved in the execution of the supposed
infiltrator, although he never offered much in the way of details.
In December of 1943,
the ROCI partisans welcomed into their ranks and experienced fighter who
organized extensive firearm drills. This increased the skills and confidence,
but left them with a little ammunition, which was used up during training.
That lack of ammo.
It became fatal when the fascist militia showed up on December the 13th,
since Primo and his comrades as good, not fight back.
Eight partisans managed to escape. A Primo and two companions were arrested.
It was a little surprise when those who were captured discovered the identity of
their interrogator, it was that same experienced instructor.
It was actually a fascist spy after a long interrogation,
preload admitted to being a Jew, partly out of fatigue,
but partly out of the surge of haughty pride,
he was deported to the concentration camp for solely descended.
His short partisan Korea later, he learns that his rock climbing friends,
Sandra Hood joined the resistance. His career had also been cut short,
not by capture,
but by the bursts of a Tommy gun shot by a 15 year old black shirts Walla for
Sali. Primo was generally treated well, but in February of 1944,
the SS took over the camp. One day,
the Jewish prisoners were suddenly told to get ready to be moved to a new camp.
The following day Primo and the others had only a single night to prepare for
the relocation. One brief exquisite night, they wished would never end,
but as he would eventually write, Dawn came upon them like a portrayal 650 men,
women and children were transferred to the train station.
Remote noticed the name of their destination scrolled on a sign.
It sounded like Austerlitz, but it wasn't.
The convoy was headed to Europe's heart of darkness,
650 deep OTs crammed into 12 wagons traveled four days and four
nights food was scarce and water was completely absent mass like castle.
The deportees had no room to lie down and no privacy for their physiological
needs.
The humanity and dignity were gradually dissolved like bodies and hydrofluoric
acid. The train arrived at Auschwitz in the dead of night.
The doors opened onto a large platform and the prisoners were subjected to the
infamous selection process by a group of SS offices.
Based on age health and fitness, the company is divided into two groups.
Able-bodied men and women would be sent to labor camps.
The others were transferred to bark an hour where the gas chambers in
crematorium were located.
Primo noted how the SS method of selection was more random than it was initially
appeared. Those who by chance climbed down on a certain side of the convoy were
arbitrarily sent to die. This is how Amelia or a girl from Milan was killed.
Emilia who was curious and cheerful intelligence and ambitious Emilia,
who was three years old. Primo was part of a group of 95.
Men transferred to a satellite labor camp.
Eight kilometers from Auschwitz twenty-five young women were taken to a separate
female labor camp,
the other 530 prisoners of facility with debt within two days,
Primo's new destination was called mano.
It's a camp dedicated to the maintenance of a subsidiary plans of the chemical
giants. IgG Farben.
These chemical plants were intended to produce a synthetic rubber for the German
war effort called Buena. Hence the camp was known as Buena mano it's.
Once their Primo was subjected to the next stages of the dehumanization process,
it was stripped of all his belongings, completely shaved,
and then given a striped uniform,
the foot cloths and independence had been fashioned down to the talents.
The sacred Shoals used by Jews during prayer.
He then received a tattoo number one seven four five one seven from then on
Primo.
And the other prisoners would be referred to only as a series of digits or
collectively as pieces Primo soon realized he needed to just sharpen his wits.
If he wanted to survive,
he had to use his reasons to tame and contrast the senselessness of this new
ecosystem. The Campbell logger in German,
it became clear to him that knowing the German language would give him an edge
prisoners who did not understand orders could immediately be sent to the gas
chambers. During one of these selections,
then promote learned the value of keeping his feet healthy, uh,
Carlos or blister.
It could degenerate into a nasty infection leading to death by sepsis.
Those prisoners who did not die immediately would often develop a limp.
They were slower than the rest, always at the back of the cues to collect food.
Eventually they would be picked at selection. Finally,
levy learns that everybody mano it's was a thief.
Even a friend might steal your bread, your spoon or your shoes,
or even a button thread.
Why anything else that could be exchanged for more food at the black market
within the camp,
besides all that Primo had to contend with the harshness of hard labor moving
heavy construction material from one place to the other.
The shifts were grueling with barely any breaks. Labor has received daily food.
Ration of 500 grams of breads needed with sawdust two balls of watery soup.
And the little margarine Knights did not offer any respites from physical
exhaustion. Prisoners were crammed into overcrowded,
dormitories rife with parasites and pathogens of all kinds.
Campbell authorities,
trying to deal with these infestations by disinfecting the dormitories with
nitrogen mustard, vapor highly toxic for the human inhabitants,
but harmless for the microbes then were supervised at a distance by the SS gods.
But their immediate overseers and tormentors were the capos prisoners selected
by camp administration to direct labor,
maintain discipline and to punish and to humiliate their fellow inmates.
After suffering a foot injury, Primo spent two weeks in the medical block.
The experience gave him some rest from hard labor,
and it's the chance to witness the capita is at work within the infirmary.
The doctors were also prisoners who happened to have medical degrees,
but the nurses and orderlies that no previous professional experience,
they showed no respect for their patients,
stealing their food and bartering it for cigarettes or clothes.
Often they would administer beatings to be ill or subject them to humiliating
punishments. If a patient was thought to be dead,
two orderlies would beat him with oxide news for minutes on end until they were
sure that he wouldn't move any longer.
Even the personnel operated the infamous shower rooms and the gas chambers were
inmates.
They SS selected them from among the ordinary criminals rather than the other
so-called undesirables.
It was they who led the other prisoners inside the showers. It was,
they handle the metal containers labeled Zipline B,
but the destruction of all kinds of them in before putting the gas to bodies
into the ovens,
a special squad of overseers cut off the hair and extracted that gold teeth.
The ashes were then scattered and fields and gardens is a fertilizer for this.
No, man is an Island.
Despite his intelligence and adaptability Primo could not survive on his own.
He needed a friends. And even in that hell,
he was able to find some remarkable companions. People like Lorenzo,
a civilian construction, Wacker risking his own life.
Lorenzo managed to smuggle extra rations of food to the scrawny Primo,
allowing him to survive.
There was also a French inmates in charge of transporting food rations.
Joel wanted to learn Italian. So he pulled some strings to have Primo assigned,
to help with its relatively light duties in a memorable moments while
transporting a VAT of soup. Primo torsional about Dante's divine comedy,
but Primo's best friend in mano it's was another Italian Jew.
Alberto Dalla Volta, unlike Primo, Alberto was extroverted and gregarious,
a chronic optimist who was able to communicate and network with everybody within
the camp. Alberto,
his positive energy in the face of despair was so overwhelming that Primo
described him as one against whom the weapons of the night were blunted.
At the end of 1944. Pre-med had his life saved by science camp.
Authorities were looking for prisoners with the knowledge of chemistry to work
within the Buena labs. He eagerly volunteered,
sat an exam and was accepted for the role. It was still a slave labor,
but one that could be carried out in doors rather than in the violence.
Polish Windsor Primo was under strict supervision,
but manage to carry out small acts of sabotage.
Not that they would need it constantly harassed by Soviet bombing raids.
The of plant never produced a single gram of synthetic rubber.
When the air raid sirens blasted German supervisors rushed to the shelters as
well. Primo and the other prisoners were left in the lab.
This gave him the chance to explore the lab scavenging for useful loot.
He even tried using lab supplies for food.
He experiments by using cotton fritters or glycerin, which were nutritious,
but disgusting.
One day he stumbled upon some small metal rods and he brought them to Alberto.
The two realized that rods were made of cerium the same material used as Flint
and cigarette lighters. They're resourceful.
Alberto found out that some prisoners sat up a clandestine workshop to produce
lighters, risking execution prima,
but I stole all of the rods and sold them on the black market in exchange for
some breads and enough to keep them alive for an extra couple of months.
By January, 1945, the Soviets weren't just flying bombing missions overhead.
They had reached the prison Gates,
the SS received orders to evacuate Auschwitz and all of its dependence.
Just on the Eve of relocation.
Primo fell ill with Scarlet fever and must have to die in the camp infirmary.
Alberto Lynn's 11,000 prisoners were to be transferred to another camp.
The two friends bade farewell to each other one time.
Primo was certain that he was going to die while Alberto might ultimately move
on and survive. This was not the case.
The few SS left at the infantry were ordered to kill all of the patients,
but they flooded in a hurry. As the Soviets approached on the other hand,
most of the 11,000 prisoners on the move were slaughtered in what became a death
March. Roberto was one of them in the final days in the Manu it's infirmary,
Primo partially recovered alongside a French friend Shaul.
He did his best to help the patients by scavenging food and medicines from the
abandoned SS barracks.
Only one of the inmates in their cat died as Primo and Charles were burying him
in the snow.
They met the gaze of four Soviet Scouts on horseback now in the cab of Russian
liberator's Primo and other Italian prisoners, but well-treated,
but it took seven months for them to return home,
the used of disorganization and a lack of working railways,
Primo meandered through Ponant Ukrainian, better Reese, Romania, Hungary,
and Austria. Before finally reaching tearin. The journey was not all unpleasant.
On the contrary,
the Russians did their best to feed the ex-prisoners even ensuring they have a
monthly ration of 10 ounces of tobacco, the red army soldiers,
medical personnel, and ex-prisoners also organized film nights stage plays.
And for RT shows during his Odyssey, as usual,
Primo was able to forge alliances with friends impervious to the blows of
darkness. He prevented a man who shared the same name as his father Cesare,
who used a mixture of hand gestures, Roman street,
dialect and positive enthusiasm to communicate with local tradesman and hustle
for food. He also met an older man named Marto. Now Homer rugged Greek veteran.
He warned Primo never to be caught bare footed because in a war you always need
shoes. And when Primo noted that the war was now over Moto replied solemnly.
Well, it's a always.
Premier reached cheer in, in August of 1945,
his mother and sister believing him to be dead,
that he recognized him almost immediately upon his return.
Primo felt compelled to tell a story as is the case with many authors writing
became the kind of therapy to cope with the trauma that he had survived.
His notes on the sanitary conditions at Manoa wits were published in a
prestigious medical journal in 1946.
His account became known as the Auschwitz report and played a huge part in
shining a light on the horrific events of world war II,
Primo expanders on those notes drafting his first book survival in Auschwitz
in the breakfast,
Primo warned against the dangers of irrational hatred is it can do easily become
the basis for an organized system. Stating many people,
many nations can find themselves holding that every stranger is an enemy.
This conviction lies deep down like some latent infection.
It betrays itself only in random disconnected acts and does not lie at the base
of a system of reason.
But when the unspoken dogma becomes the major premise in a syllogism,
then at the end of the chain, there is the log of the book in Italy,
the UK and other countries it's titled. If this is a man after a poem,
authored by Primo and it's he ponders. If a human being can retain his nature,
even after his dignity has been trampled on premium himself,
did retain his humanity solely returning to life. In September of 1947,
he took up a job as a chemist at Seaver, a varnish factory in December,
he married his fiance. This was Lucia.
[inaudible] one of the few who had listened to the stories of the camps.
And you helped him edit his writings.
The two had two children Lorenza in 1948 and Renzo in 1957 while working at
Siva Primo succeeded in publishing his memoirs in 1949,
a small publisher released the first edition of survival,
but with little promotion or interest behind it, it was only in 1958,
the publishing Johns,
I nowadays widely distributed it attracting international attention in 1963,
Primo released as followup to survival known in the U S as the reawakening,
this book recounts Primos adventures while returning home, after his liberation,
despite the overall positive and lighter tone, there is a dark hue,
the Italian title translators, the truce,
which is probably closer to what Primo was going for.
He considered the period of his adventures to be a truce,
a truce between the end of world war two and the onset of the cold war or the
brief playful ends of all laughter surviving the darkness.
And before readapting to society with darkness stood side on an even
more personal level,
Primo may have felt that his journey was a period of peace between the cosmic
horrors of the camp and the intimate struggle of his depression,
which reoccurred in the late 1940s,
as more to it said war is always in the outer world. Yes,
but also perhaps within our souls, following the success of his first books,
Primo continued to write focusing primarily on collections of short stories and
he could be classified as science fictional fantasy has most accomplished effort
in this genre is questi all the can Tori and it's the narrator forges a
friendship with the captive center.
The creatures rational side is usually preeminence until he falls in love with
the narrators girlfriends driven by passion.
The animal side emerges and the center escapes and a frenzy of lost levees.
Most famous story collection though is the periodic table of
1975.
This collection was crowned as the best scientific book ever in 2006 by the
Royal institution of great Britain. Each story uses chemistry as a metaphor.
So you interpret life and is titled after an elements of the periodic table.
For example, iron is about Primo's friendship with Sandra,
the rock climber who trains him for a future made of iron sulfur is about an
engineer at a plot to prevent say,
disastrous accidents involving an industrial sized boy learns a stash of sulfur.
In other words, he tames a piece of chaotic machinery with his intellect,
both sulfur and Castillo. This tour,
I deal with a recurring theme of levees,
the conflict between reason and chaos and eternal struggle without.
Clear winner.
The rear view mirror,
the main conflict of levies live shifted from external to internal to better
understand levees struggle with depression.
It's important to consider his private life in the views of biographer,
Carol angrier and Ian Thompson loving saw the power of reason as a holding bank.
The dark irrational force of clinical depression,
according to Anglia levies depression was the result of a troubled relationship
with his mother runs of a sexless frustrating marital life. I as theses,
uh, disputed by many critics, you believe Levy's depression was hereditary.
His grandfather suffered from it and to commit suicide.
Another controversial claim is that the ordeal that Manu it's did not worse than
Primo's depression. On the contrary, it honed his survival skills and intellect.
Primo levy confirmed this to American writer,
Philip Roth throughout the 1970s and 1980s,
Primo levy sought medical help to treat his condition. A fact,
he largely kept hidden from the public and most friends,
a rare ally in his moments of darkness was German pen.
Pal had the Schmidt mass who corresponded with him for 17 years since
1966,
had he wanted to documents and understand the crimes of the third Reich and
especially the complicity of IAG Farb and chemical works.
That relationship became a true friendship as they wrote about their respective
marital problems,
how to embrace them face to face on two occasions in 1968 and 1971.
How do you notice how Primo was charismatic and self-assured on their first
encounter, but appeared nervous and depressed three years later.
And yet Primo's public persona had never betrayed his malady,
delivering lectures and interviews with a pleasant and humorous demeanor that
they frequently clashed with revisionist historians,
especially those who minimize the cruelty of the camp system by pointing out
other nations.
And other times had done something similar as he did not pull any punches.
Primo found himself embroiled in controversy with the Israeli government as
well, criticizing his actions against Palestinians.
He famously declared that Palestinians were Israel's Jews.
They were the new victims of those would once been persecuted themselves
83 had he died at age 65.
Her death precipitated another depressive episode for levy. Nonetheless,
he completed what would be his last major work, the drowns and the saved,
which was published in 1986.
It is a collection of essays on the themes of the camps,
survival and prisoners collaboration with their capitalists in January and
February,
1987 levy met three times with critic and biographer Giovanni Tessio in the
interviews.
Primo confirmed that he had suffered from depression as a teenager and spoke at
length about his father, but was quite reticent in talking about his mother.
When Tessio tried to arrange a fourth meeting or the declines,
he was going through a dark patch, he was suffering too much.
The two would never meet again on April the 11th, 1997,
Bremer Levy's body was found lying at the bottom of the stairwell in the
apartment block where he lived since birth, the police ruled it to be a suicide.
Some biographers agree with this blaming Primo suicide on a major depressive
episode brought on by his unresolved lifelong issues.
Others believe the roots of Primo's illness lies in the trauma of Auschwitz.
Some dismiss the idea of suicide altogether,
believing his death to be an accident.
It may have been caused by dizziness and disorientation side effects of
antidepressants bus. We won't a solution here.
What matters to us and people worldwide is his legacy and his works some of the
most important living testimonies from the horrors of the Shaw.
Premier levy taught us that when the conviction that every stranger is an enemy
becomes dogma. Then at the end of the chain,
there is death on an industrial level,
but humankind has not learned this yet elsewhere. In other times,
other chains have been formed. And at the end of those chains,
there were the gulags of Kalima.
There were a masker that's Rebecca and the Casani pits,
the killing fields in Cambodia and in Rwanda, Sabra and Shatila.
And the list goes on Wars always.
And the weapons of the Knights are still sharp.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. Thank you for watching.